Українські прапори здіймаються один за одним над десятками
звільнених міст і селищ України.
ЗСУ за лічені дні відбили більшу частину окупованих районів Харківщини,
а це тисячі квадратних кілометрів, включно з важливими
транспортними вузлами Куп’янськом та Ізюмом.
Місцями ЗСУ навіть вийшли на кордон з Росією.
Це одне з найбільших досягнень української армії від початку війни.
У чому ж секрет успіху такого блискавичного контрнаступу?
Я думаю, що це поєднання трьох обставин.
По-перше, російські війська виснажені,
їхнє тилове забезпечення виснажено,
значна частина офіцерського складу знищена.
Протягом останніх кількох місяців ми спостерігали погіршення
бойового духу в російських військах, у них немає бажання воювати.
Це перше. По-друге, впливає зброя, надана Заходом,
особливо ракети великої дальності. Такі можливості дуже
допомогли порушити та знищити російську логістику,
артилерію, командні пункти, справді створивши безліч проблем
для росіян на їхніх територіях, через що їм важко зрозуміти,
що відбувається, й оперативно відповідати.
І по-третє, це заслуга українського генштабу та ЗСУ.
Вони дисципліновані. Вони виконали добру роботу
із захисту інформації та оперативної безпеки.
Вони обдурили росіян з приводу того, куди мав бути
завданий головний удар, відкрито говорили про атаку на Херсон
в той час, коли головний удар насправді відбувся на півночі.
Тож ми спостерігаємо справді найвищий рівень виконання тактичного планування.
А це, як каже українська сторона, "акт розпачу та помсти" за програш на полі бою.
У відповідь на контрнаступ ЗСУ російська армія здійснила масований ракетний обстріл
низки об'єктів критичної інфраструктури, внаслідок чого на певний час
були повністю знеструмлені низка українських регіонів.
На думку експерта з питань Східної Європи, австрійського професора Ґергарда Манґотта,
Путін зараз може мало що протиставити українцям на фронті,
а удари по цивільних об'єктах - це воєнний злочин, який не змінює ситуації на полі бою.
Росія терміново потребує більше солдатів. І доки не буде оголошено загальну мобілізацію,
неможливо буде відправити на фронт стільки солдатів, скільки потрібно Росії
для утримання завойованих територій, не кажучи вже про завоювання нових.
Але російське керівництво боїться оголошувати загальну мобілізацію з політичних причин.
Це був би вкрай непопулярний захід.
На думку ж німецького політолога Ганса-Геннінґа Шредера,
удари Росії по українській інфраструктурі - це не просто акт помсти,
а військова відповідь російської армії, адже ні на що інше вона на даний момент більше не здатна.
Руйнування інфраструктури на сході України ускладнює українській армії наступ.
Якщо власні війська надто слабкі, а моральний дух недостатньо високий,
щоб утримувати позиції, то використовуються ті засоби, які є,
- в даному випадку далекобійна артилерія та ракети.
Чого чекати далі? Ґергард Манґотт не виключає, що Кремль тестує нову тактику ведення війни,
але експерт переконаний, що вона приречена на провал.
Це може бути підготовкою до війни проти цивільних цілей - проти транспортної інфраструктури,
інфраструктури електропостачання, опалення.
Я вважаю, що нинішнє російське керівництво здатне на таке.
І це, безперечно, спроба знизити моральний дух українського населення.
Але я гадаю, це неефективна спроба. Українці сповнені рішучості
вигнати окупантів з країни. І холодна зима їх не налякає.
Зважаючи на успішний контрнаступ української армії,
Пентагон отримує від Києва дедалі більше запитів на постачання американської зброї.
Найбільшим попитом користуються високотехнологічні реактивні системи
залпового вогню HIMARS, які ЗСУ використовують
проти російських складів боєприпасів та постачання.
Ми вважаємо, що зусилля Росії не увінчалися успіхом і не увінчаються успіхом.
І коли йдеться про допомогу Україні в обороні, і коли йдеться про забезпечення
значного тиску на Росію з метою припинення цієї війни, то ми маємо забезпечити,
щоб наш власний альянс був настільки сильним і рішучим,
наскільки це можливо для стримування російської агресії.
Я думаю, що ви зараз бачите реальну єдність у дії.
Це і зустріч контактної групи, і неймовірна рішучість наших союзників,
наших партнерів і насамперед українського народу. Взаємодія дійсно на всіх рівнях.
Розмір допомоги Вашингтона Києву цього року сягнув понад 10 з половиною мільярдів доларів.
Допомагає Києву і Берлін. Минулого тижня Німеччина надала сучасну
артилерійську станцію радіолокації COBRA та зенітні установки "Гепард".
Найближчим часом Німеччина поставить сучасну систему ППО IRIS-T
і ще дві системи знаходяться у виробництві.
А от надати сучасні танки Leopard 2 канцлер Німеччини Олаф Шольц відмовляється.
Він відхилив відповідне прохання прем'єр-міністра України Дениса Шмигаля.
При цьому комітет Бундестагу з оборони вже давно вимагає відправити в Україну танки.
Канцлер був у нас на засіданні комітету. Він відповів на наші запитання і сказав,
що готовий до відправки танків лише в тому випадку, якщо американці
почнуть постачати свій танк Abrahams або французи їхній аналог - "Леклерк".
Ми ж, ліберали, заявили, що буде краще, якщо ми після консультацій з нашими партнерами
зробимо перший крок і не чекатимемо, поки хтось інший зробить це.
І я можу сказати вам з надійного джерела, що саме Сполучені Штати не будуть
вказувати нам, мовляв, робіть те чи це. Але я дуже добре знаю, що вони
не дуже засмутяться, якщо ми візьмемо на себе цю роль.
Тому що в такому разі у США, які роблять колосальний внесок у виживання України,
був би надійний партнер у Європі. І це була б Федеративна Республіка Німеччина,
зважаючи на економічну міць і потенціал нашої країни.
Як може Росія відповісти на контрнаступ України?
За словами опитаних DW експертів, окрім хаотичних ракетних обстрілів,
Росія нині небагато що може протиставити.
Я думаю, що Росія дедалі більше має проблеми з поповненням кадрових резервів взагалі.
І зараз ці проблеми стали просто величезними.
Заплановані батальйони і полки нема з кого створювати, у кращому разі йдеться
хіба що про посилені роти.
Крім того, Росія має проблему з військовою підготовкою.
Адже починаючи з третього-четвертого місяця війни на фронт було кинуто
багато офіцерів та військових інструкторів.
Тож зараз цього персоналу не вистачає,
і ви можете собі лише уявити якість нашвидкуруч сколочених військових частин,
які були підготовлені, ймовірно, малоосвіченим персоналом і яких зараз в екстреному порядку
кидають на якусь ділянку фронту, де найбільше потрібно підкріплення.
При цьому застосування ядерної зброї Росією у відповідь на український контрнаступ
є малоймовірним, вважає колишній командувач армії США у Європі генерал Бен Ходжес.
Адже у такому випадку США не могли б залишатися бездіяльними
- серед іншого й з огляду на те, що такі країни, як Китай, Північна Корея
та Іран уважно стежать за реакцією Вашингтона.
У росіян немає іншого вибору, окрім як продовжити намагатися вбивати
невинних людей, запускаючи ракети по житлових районах, як вони це й роблять,
оскільки вони не можуть за допомогою сухопутних військ зупинити ЗСУ.
Російську авіацію майже не видно, а російський флот ховається за Кримом,
тож я просто не бачу великої ймовірності якихось значних воєнних дій.
І тому росіяни намагатимуться компенсувати це запуском ракет по містах,
поки вони зовсім не закінчаться або їх не зупинять.
Отже, експерти прогнозують подальше просування український військ на північному сході України.
Продовжуватиметься й перший етап деокупації на півдні - це правобережна частина Херсонщини.
Там окупанти фактично відрізані від можливості постачання і підсилення фронту
за рахунок перекидання з лівого берега Дніпра, а саме з Криму.
Водночас Дніпро як природна загорожа буде стримувати й українські війська,
тому передбачити перебіг деокупації лівого берега поки складно.